a new nintendo direct is imminent and
metroid prime might be coming to the
switch later this year all this and more
on today's gamespot news
for the past few weeks a nintendo direct
no not that one has been rumored to be
in the works for before the end of june
in the 11th hour nintendo did confirm
that a direct is indeed happening
but it's going to be one of its many
presentations exclusively dealing with
third party titles so expect to see some
news on games like mario plus rabbids
sparks of hope rather than the sequel to
breath of the wild jeff grubb of
gamespot's sister site giantbomb has
stated he has heard that nintendo will
be spreading out its presentations over
the summer so if this direct doesn't
speak to you you might not have to wait
long for one that does speaking of jeff
grub and waiting this year is the 20th
anniversary of the beloved metroid prime
and it seems that nintendo might finally
be ready to put out a remaster of this
classic in time for that celebration
grubb reports that he has been told
quote pretty definitively that the
remaster will be one of nintendo's big
holiday 2022 releases grubb also notes
that rather than a package of the entire
trilogy this release will only be a
remaster of the first metroid prime and
while there are plans to eventually
re-release two and three those titles
might not get the same level of overhaul
but the leaks don't stop there
potentially revealed are also july's
playstation plus games leaked via d labs
it seems that subscribers on every tier
will have access to crash bandicoot 4
it's about time the dark pictures
anthology man of medan and arcade agedon
when the monthly games refresh on july
5th not only is the recently released
fourth crash bandicoot a great get on
its own but the remastered insane
trilogy of the first three games is
already available via the playstation
plus collection so players can complete
the entire bandicoot saga for those that
have checked out supermassive's latest
horror game the quarry and are itching
for more man of medan is the first
release in the developers dark pictures
anthology series featuring similar
mechanics and spooky delights the final
title arcade agenda released in early
access last summer is a multiplayer
shooter set in an arcade game with both
pvp and pve elements while it has flown
relatively under the radar since
launching its inclusion in next month's
ps plus lineup is sure to give it a shot
in the arm of course with new ps plus
games incoming that means that rps plus
games outgoing so these are the last few
days for you to claim before they're
gone on july 5th something else that's
gone is a potential hideo kojima
superhero project in a tweet thread the
iconic developer mentions how he shelved
plans for a quote radical hard-boiled
action film that pits a special
detective squad against superheroes
after the release of amazon prime's the
boys a tv show with a similar scope
kojima states that he pictured one of
the actors in his latest game death
stranding mads mikkelsen in the lead
role kojima if you're watching this i am
begging you please bring this project
back to life while you at home to mourn
the loss of a hard-boiled detective
story helmed by hideo kojima distract
yourself with the overwatch 2 beta
starting on june 28th which you can sign
up for now on both pc and console if
that's not your bag on the same day jane
foster aka the mighty thor will become a
playable hero in marvel's avengers with
her own unique moves and battle pass
separate from the original god of
thunder
and that's gonna be it for today gang
thank you so much for joining me on my
very first gamespot news roundup please
consider liking subscribing and for
everyone that already has thank you for
helping us reach 5 million subscribers i
really take a lot of credit for that
we'll see you tomorrow for more news and
gaming
you